رجل قضى معظم حياته في
الولايات المتحدة.  توفي هذا الأسبوع بعد أن تم
ترحيله إلى العراق ، وتعتقد عائلة جون جيمي الدودز
أنه توفي لأنه
لم يتمكن من الحصول على الأنسولين لعلاج
مرض السكري ، كما يقولون إنه كان يعيش في
شوارع بغداد على الرغم من أنه تم
ترحيله إلى العراق كجزء من ترامب.
حملة الهجرة التي شنتها الإدارة الأمريكية ،
ولكن هذا هو الشيء الذي لم يسبق له
أن ذهب إلى العراق ، حتى أنه لم يولد هناك ، حيث
تشير التقارير إلى أنه مواطن عراقي
ولد في اليونان ، لكنه قضى
الغالبية العظمى من حياته في الولايات
المتحدة ويعيش في ديترويت  أريد أن
أريكم هذا الفيديو الآن لجيم
يتحدث على ما يبدو قبل وفاته جيدًا ، لسنا
متأكدين عندما تم تصوير هذا الفيديو ، تمت
مشاركته على Facebook بواسطة
شارة محامي الهجرة في Jimmy ، إدوارد
، Oka وانضم إلي الآن من ديترويت ، لذا
متى حصلت  التأكيد على
وفاة جيمي ألدو كان يوم الثلاثاء
قبل يومين
كيف تم ترحيل ما
حدث له بالضبط والذي أدى إلى
إعادته إلى العراق وهو بلد
لم يسبق له مثيل.  حتى أن السيد الدعوة
كما ذكرت لم يولد في العراق ،
فقد ولد في اليونان ، على عكس
الولايات المتحدة ، لا تمنح اليونان جنسية حق
المولد للأفراد الذين ولدوا هناك ، لذلك احتفظ
بجنسية والده الذي
كان لاجئًا عراقيًا.  وصل لاحقًا مع
عائلته كلاجئ في الولايات
المتحدة وعاش هنا طوال حياته ، وكان لديه
عدة إدانات جنائية أدت
إلى وضعه في إجراءات الترحيل ،
ويشمل تاريخه الإجرامي غزو منزل
لاقتحام منزل جاره
وسرقته  بعض الأدوات خارج مرآب جاره
والسلوك غير المنضبط وحيازة
أشياء الماريجوانا التي
سأعتبرها بسيطة نسبيًا ، كان جيمي مصابًا بالفصام بجنون العظمة
، وكان يعاني
من قلق شديد
واكتئاب شديد ، وأعتقد أن
تاريخه الإجرامي كان مرتبطًا جميعًا
بعقله.  الصحة ، في كثير من الأحيان ،
لسوء الحظ ، يسيران جنبًا إلى جنب
ولهذا السبب انتهى به المطاف في الترحيل
القائمة صحيحة لأن العراق بدأ في
إعادة قبول المرحلين قبل بضع سنوات
كجزء من صفقة مع إدارة ترامب
حتى لا يكونوا
على قائمة الدول المحظورة من
دخول الولايات المتحدة
ونتيجة لذلك لأنه كان لديه سجل جنائي
تم وضعه.  في تلك القائمة ثم تم
اعتقاله وترحيله في نهاية المطاف ،
هذا ما حدث له
هذا صحيح تمامًا وقد تم
احتجازه بالفعل من يونيو 2017 حتى
ديسمبر 2018 وتم الإفراج عنه وبعد
حوالي خمسة أشهر فقط بعد ذلك ستة أشهر
بعد ذلك تم القبض عليه مرة أخرى
بالجليد وبدنًا وبقوة
وضد إرادته يتم
ترحيله إلى دولة لم يرحلها من قبل